[Music]
unis overload Ryan Reynolds and Blake
Lively's two daughters made their public
debut Ryan and Blake proudly showed off
their beautiful family as the Deadpool
star was honored with a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame I want to thank
my wife
Blake you make everything better I mean
absolutely everything in my life better
you've given us two of the most
incredible children that I could ever
hope to have does it mean to have Blake
the two girls here oh it's everything I
mean just not not only just that my
family here but this is like this only
happens once in a lifetime and normally
we don't drop the whole family out like
this but but I just thought I would
regret this 20 years if I didn't have my
kids here as well so so we all we are
decided to collectively just come down
here and one big movement and be a part
of this these cameras caught the
couple's eldest daughter two year-old
James hamming it up could she follow in
her famous parents footsteps looks like
James might be getting into showbiz or
she looks antsy to get into showbiz
don't know about that no there will be
no showbiz in her future unless she's
until she's 30
I think she's that's a safe time for her
to enter they enter the game
[Music]